the AI thing is a very big deal because
it's one of those technologies that is
kind of like oxygen it's here and it's
not going anywhere and it's going to
continue to be a big factor in our
universe just where we are right now
knowing that this is the base this is
just the beginning this is Ask Jeeves
what if all these things that happening
culture are actually incredibly mappable
what's amazing is if you know how to be
a propped engineer and put into the
query things you can start mapping
things that have historically been magic
or gray or creative and you're starting
to make it black and white that changes
the world like Jack has to come up with
his stuff but like if you put in these
are the 700 last top 100 songs that have
hit in culture what is the common thread
or what should i title it we're starting
to really get into a place that changes
the world we've all lived in it's that
big it's not like it can make a picture
for me the predictive AI stuff is
bananas